[Musique]
j'ai commencé des récoltes un peu dans
le monde entier entre autres quand je
suis allé au Japon faire nombre
d'expositions j'ai ramené des choses et
j'ai travaillé avec je me suis dit tiens
c'est intéressant je vais développer et
j'ai fait un gros travail sur l'Égypte
en me posant la question qu'est-ce qu'un
artiste contemporain peut faire avec 5
6000 hommes décalage avec les mêmes
matériaux qui entouraient les Égyptiens
à cette époque ça j'ai fait un travail
sur le long terme je suis allé plus
d'une dizaine d'années en Egypte de
façon très régulière et j'ai ramassé
tout un tas de choses en Egypte sur le
terrain avec les matériaux qui étaient
susceptibles de retourner les Égyptiens
avec le décalage que je viens de citer
vous savez que j'ai mis le pied en
Islande c'est-à-dire qu'on a
l'impression qu'on arrive un peu à la
Genèse on a des paysages où il y a
personne on est tout seul et il y a
cette dimension où on a l'impression
d'être à la fois sur terre mais dans un
milieu céleste il y a quelque chose qui
se passe entre la Terre et l'univers et
on se dit tiens peut-être comme ça qui a
commencé
il y a une espèce de jeunesse quelque
part mais aussi cette solitude où on
retrouve dans le paysage on est seul
mais vraiment seul c'est-à-dire il y a
pas d'habitation il y a personne il y a
des kilomètres et des kilomètres mais en
même temps moi ce que je vais faire
ressurgir c'est c'est quelque chose de
ce rapport entre la terre et le céleste
donc le noir bah oui ça va nous faire
penser à quelque chose qui est dans
l'univers mais le noir c'est aussi ce
qui se passe sur terre avec la lave et
on a énormément de volcans en Islande
donc on a énormément de sable noir avec
des des degrés divers c'est là que c'est
intéressant quand on a une palette aussi
large c'est-à-dire que si on a du sable
noir fin bah c'est une palette mais on a
du sable noir aussi un petit peu plus
grossier sur les plages mais qui se
mélangent à la nacre et qui devient un
autre noir et bon on a autrement une
palette d'or qu'on a une palette de
verre comme c'est le printemps et toute
la nature qui revient
on voit que j'ai une palette quand même
très coloriste
je dirais que je vais reprendre le mot
de soulage
pas dans le noir et le noir c'est de la
couleur
mais ça dépend comment ça se vit avec la
lumière
donc je me suis pas encore promis
c'est ça je découvre le terrain je me
promène je vais à la rencontre des gens
j'écoute un peu comment ils vivent que
qu'est-ce qu'ils mangent comment ils
sont quel rapport ils ont avec la nature
avec les éléments qui les entourent on
le sait très bien ça de toute façon on
ne construit pas n'importe comment dans
un endroit précis on utilise les
matériaux de l'endroit pour faire sa
maison pour faire son lieu pour manger
pour faire c'est ça que je vais voir je
sais que je vais chercher
après quand j'ai un petit peu compris ce
qui se passe c'est moi qui fait le
chemin et qui va voir un petit peu
comment ça se passe comment on vit ça
comme je disais tout à l'heure on est
face aux éléments et on est face à une
nature qui est sublime mais très
dangereuse quelque part aussi donc cette
fragilité là il faut aussi la prendre en
compte et c'est aussi ça qui doit
resurgir dans les toiles
on a l'impression quand on est enfin moi
c'est mon impression c'est mon ressenti
c'est de faire partie de cette nature
et en même temps bon on n'est rien du
tout
je suis en train de me dire quand j'y
suis quand je travaille le sable je sais
que je vais revenir à cette dimension là
et on foulera la faible poussière que je
serai à un moment donné